[Music]
news from Harley and Arthur director
Todd Phillips published two new stills
from the eagerly awaited sequel on his
Instagram channel in one image we see
Arthur imprisoned at Arkham Asylum
indicated by the hatch on his cell door
in the second image he appears to be
outside the prison at his side is Dr
harleen quinzel Alias Harley Quinn
played by Lady Gaga her look reveals
that she finds the Joker visibly
fascinating in terms of content Joker
fol ad do is set to continue the story
of the first part Arthur will receive
support from Harley Quinn after he ends
up in a psychiatric War presumably as in
the comics she will initially work as a
psychiatrist and later fall in love with
her patient Arthur and become infected
by his Madness the movie has been
conceived as a musical and is therefore
likely to differ significantly from the
style of its predecessor until the
planned Cinema release those responsible
still have a little time left to put the
finishing touches to the film Joker 2
fol ad do start with Keen Phoenix and
Lady Gaga is slated for release in
theaters on October 4th
[Music]